salut les louches voici cette nouvelle
intro vous avez compris le concept je
récupère les intros que vous ne demandez
de faire de la vidéo précédente donc là
vous pouvez mettre dans les commentaires
de les intros pour les futurs vidéo
aujourd'hui nous allons rentrer dans la
matrice nous allons pénétrer l'univers
du code binaire des héros d un et aussi
du bois parce qu'on va utiliser un casse
tête qui m'a rendu ouvre quand je l'aï
vu en photo qui s'appelle binelli
s'était créé ici et le concept est
extrêmement simple il faut réussir à
ouvrir c'est un petit peu comme un
cadenas et loïc si mes cheveux sont dans
le champ tu me le dis qu'ils hésitent
jamais
parce qu'on a proposé des solutions dans
la dernière vidéo quand il ya les
cheveux dans le champ tu peux tourner
l'image
merci de suivre les commentaires loïc un
petit peu ça chez qui les lie tous en
plus bon d'un côté ce casse-tête mahler
dur et de l'autre côté il m'a l'air
vraiment envisageable parce qu'on voit
tout cette vidéo sort le mercredi à 6
heures comme tout mais vidéo du mercredi
et des fois ces deux jours et ce à six
heures du matin aussi mais j'en profite
pour vous dire que ce samedi lhc en
dédicace à amiens à la fnac damien vous
avez les infos sur mon site et ce mois
d'octobre fut également un spectacle à
lyon et à toulon attention aux lions
s'est remplie à 80% vous avez le lien
d'un site dans la description il ya tous
les ans je vais procéder par étapes je
vais essayer en fait de le faire monter
de plus en plus haut donc l'idée ça va
être de reculer ses tiges offert mesure
donc la première la première chez
obligés de libérer la beat là comme ça
voilà et si je pousse à coach que je
peux faire un chemin non là je peux pas
oui il est ok bon pas jusqu'ici ça va
dans le premier était pas trop compliqué
puisque là j'arrive à le monter
maintenant ici ah mais oui c'est là que
ça va se compliquer mais non c'est pas
du tout une bonne théorie mon truc parce
que là du coup celle de bila va
m'empêcher de faire quoi que ce soit
celui dit huard est d'accord vraiment
l'espace d'un instant je me suis battue
tout ça va aller en fait cette compil
bassam appellera si tranquille que sa
main du coup est ce que par exemple je
peux bouger lui oui parce que ça ne
porte rien du tout problème mais ce que
ici là juste là je pense que vous le
voyez il ya un trou il ya un emplacement
pour une bille donc ça veut dire que je
pourrai mettreen et là on voit qu'il ya
des zones mais il y en a aussi d'autres
ah ouais non en fait les choses je me
suis en plus du tout la difficulté
j'essaierai de vous mettre si je le
retrouve sur le site où je les prie
tumeur jojo mais un lien dans la
description aussi vers le casque est
évidemment bon là je peux pas le bouger
là non plus pas non plus là non plus la
même
en fait ce que je dis c'est que pour
mettre la vie ici il faut qu'elle oblige
puisse le pousser pour la mettre là et
pour le coup c'est pour la mettre là ça
veut dire qu'il se creuse là doit être
devant ici sinon c'est juste impossible
donc non il faut commencer par le bas
ça va être une galère non qu'est ce que
je fais je reprendre ça voilà ça ça
c'est ce que j'ai fait au débat on va
toujours faire ce que j'avais fait au
début la france
tac tac tac tac tac quoi je peux pas
bouger d'ailleurs à ce que la big la
ville va complètement bloquée et puis
tout n'aille arias il ya ça qui te si ça
ça me permet ça à la limite je peux le
descendre à lui monté ce qu'il fait
voilà 6 à coulisse et ça ça aurait déjà
coulisses et assez chaud je suis déjà
bloqué ouais en fait il faut peut-être
du coup commencé plus tôt par celui ci
pour pouvoir récupérer la bille dans
l'autre je sais pas si je suis bien
faire mais moi je me suis je me suis
compris c'est déjà pas mal
pourquoi hall a lâché en train de
l'abîmé parce que lui pas dans une
position favorable d'être déjà bloqué
c'est fou donc là je peux pas le bouger
lui parce que louis bloch ici pour qu'il
ne bloque pas il faudrait que je fasse
ça comme ça mais limite que la verrine
si je fais ça je peux faire ça et là du
coup je peux faire ça et là qu'est ce
qui n'empêche pas ce que le fait que je
lis berbie vraiment ça me atteint si ça
me permet ça me permettrait quoi ça me
permettrait d'aller plus haut pour
travailler sur lui bon pourquoi pas je
vais essayer d'aller voir ça tac tic tac
là parce que lui il peut bouger dans cet
état assurément pas parce que ça ça le
bloquerai et ça aussi c'est le bloquerai
mais la tanière chez obligés de bloquer
à cause de vie tout en pente hac lui il
a fallu qu'ils sont en position basse
avant est ce qu'il y avait une
possibilité oui lui je pouvais le
pousser à l'avant et du coup la faire ça
du coup la faire ça et ça ça fait ça
en fait ce que je veux ce que je veux
c'est à les mettre là big là bas c'est
ça que j'ai envie tu là est-ce que je
peux faire ça comme ça donc je récupère
la bic et là je remonte lui conçoit des
sens de la vie que je le récupère ce qui
me permet de remonter sur lui mais lui
ne peut pas pourquoi peut pas à cause de
ça donc la claque
ok ok j'ai fait des trucs avec elle j'ai
d'abord à libérer de vie pour pouvoir
libérer albi pour pouvoir bouger lui lui
met la ville dessus mais techniquement
ça m'avance à quoi
en fait cette ville là j'aimerais le
mettre dans lui donc lui j'aimerais
qu'ils sont en position sortie pour
charger la vie dedans mais pour faire ça
il faut que je bouge lui dans ces trous
là je sais pas si tout est très clair
mais du coup ça se mord la queue titres
pc que je des titres tu connaisses à
loïc le jeu des titres
oui bien sûr c'est quoi c'est le jeu on
dit des titres et après on doit dire
deux mots mais quel mytho ce loïc en
fait titre c'est un jeu que quand tu
quand il dit une phrase qui m'a fait
d'être un titre de film pour adultes
eh bien tu dis titre imagine je t'invite
à manger et je te serves la choucroute
et je te dis tu en veux un peu plus
d'étudiants et toi tu me dis je
prendrais bien de ce 6e b ça c'est un
titre donc la prochaine fois que tu
joues blanches de la choucroute
peut-être tu tu peut le placer le jeu je
déclare je galère de fou
parce que là j'aurais pu pousser lui
pour mettre la bille là qui est la
solution
il est où ce laisse tomber quoi gâcher
pas le choix la toussaint si vraiment il
faut crier durant les tournages l'esitpa
un chaton raccord je me rendrai chasse
tellement la merde c'est en position
trop haute pour vous ça va me faire
péter des câbles mais la cible
en fait la semaine prochaine je veux
faire un casse tête avec quelqu'un
d'autre
un invité que je vous présenterai et qui
vient d'arriver et vient d'arriver mais
je pense que le polyvalent de montant
mais c'est chaud parce que tu dois
penser à opposition comme ça comme ça
comme ça y est ce que tu comptais faire
en même temps
donc là j'ai fait ce truc exceptionnel
de revenir quasiment à la position de
départ lui par contre ça me permettrait
de bouger sauf que ça lui il faudrait
qu'ils soient dans la position de basses
tiges veulent tous ses défauts qui sont
en bas il faut qu'ils sont en bas lui il
faut qu'ils sont emballés il faut qu'ils
soient en haut on fait tourner la libye
comme lui puisse le même temps booba est
pourquoi je peux pas de marchandage peut
pas le mettre en bas à cause de lui puis
aussi il faut qu'ils sont en bave pas
que j'oublie mon but c'est de mettre
cuit en bas donc maintenant pour mettre
plus de la en passe
et lui doit être en bas maintenant ok
donc maintenant pour pouvoir le tir et à
fond comme je veux il faut que le 800 au
lui sont à 8 soit en eau lui sont en bas
pour pouvoir faire craquer donc je dis
quoi
oh oh oh bah donc là d'abord faut que je
mette lui en bas ensuite lu hao lui en
eau et lui rend où il est facile à m ok
donc j'ai dit quoi baho bochum
[Applaudissements]
mais je récupère
là je remonte la nageuse tous pour que
je voulais faire ça c'est terrible
pourquoi je peux maintenant c'est aux
eaux aubin [ __ ] c'est grave c'est je
me faire une note parce que je m'en sors
plus dans ce que je cherche en fait là
ce que je veux c'est oh oh oh eh bah si
je faisais de pas vers le haut c'est
quand même plus logique
peut-être je me faire des plans je vais
me faire des plans et là je veux que ce
soit pour oh oh bah pourquoi parce que
lui j'aimerais pouvoir le tir et ça fait
de faire mais surtout bliss que tu veux
faire donc lui oh c'est possible je
partir de lui lui j'ai besoin qu'il soit
en bas pour qu'il soit en bas j'ai lui
qui me pose problème de l'appeler à les
lui qui me pose problème
je l'appelle à aussi
unique iger
ok ok pourquoi je faisais ça parce que
je veux amener le but c'est mon but
des mureaux
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi continuer à faire le trajet
dies lui ce baromètre en bas du cou et
mis en eau et ça c'est facile je la
maintiens mon but mais se dit s'y
prendre
tak tak le doigt est redescendu elle
aussi doit pouvoir le laisser passer
voilà voilà
c'est là que je leur dise ça c'est pas
si mal
en vrai c'est pas si mal c'est à dire
que là pour la première fois je sais que
je vais le résoudre ça fait quand même
temps là que je suis dessus
ah ouais donc ça fait quasiment une
heure que je suivrai c'est rare que je
mette une heure sur un casque et en
hockey enfin d'ailleurs quand je dis je
loin d'avoir fini je je je pressens
juste que je vais pouvoir le finir non
la confiance de cartes
mon but maintenant 6-2 vision que lui
doit et en os mais lui aussi doit être
en haut et pourrait endosser la plus s
il faut qu'ils soient en haut
et autant vous dire que maintenant je
commence le jaune et de rouge à les
maîtriser un petit peu dans la série il
est bien trop pourquoi je voulais faire
ça parce que je veux pouvoir le tir est
donc hors aurait lui devrait être en bas
par contre lui peu importe donc pour
qu'ils soient en bas
oh que oui soit en bas donc maintenant
il faut que je revoie cowboys le tess
jaune oui j'ai commencé à leur donner
des noms de plus un il faut que je
retravaille le ps jaune pour leur
travail et est ce que ça vaudrait pas le
coup d'aller d'abord l'idée ray la bille
dans celui-là mais non parce que je peux
pas encore vous donc là rappelle-toi
fabien ce que tu veux faire c'est tirer
ses tirs et celui-là c'est ça ton but
ça c'est bon et du coup ça devrait me
libérer le blanc si je vais au bout de
la démarche
temmar qui est la suivante
oui ces deux là ils sont bons ce qui
veut dire maintenant ça s'accélère mon
gars j'sais pas comment une personne
regarde encore la vidéo soit 2 des gens
qui sont endormis aurait donc la claque
là du coup ça faut que je repasse en bas
ça porte vraiment bien son nom de
binaires
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait
john sheehan et eric loret
[Musique]
le fait gagner sur un état grave la
photo est là abonnez-vous à mercredi
prochain ciao
[Musique]